it
i guess that was the moment it it had
all really become real
now this this isn't a matter of just
deciding this morning you know i want to
be a labour mp this has been many months
uh in the build up and whether it goes
back to
the issues over free school meals of
dominic cummings over universal credit
the cost of living crisis you know
available in past affair or or now party
gate there's been a lot of you know
build up to this and a lot of soul
searching that's taken many sleepless
nights
but it's it's ultimately the right
decision and
i hope my former colleagues can you know
certainly if they don't agree can
understand that
well i mean some of them have said that
they think this is a terrible mistake
how can you explain it to them
well i i think like i said there's been
far too many issues where
i felt we've been on on the wrong side
and compromise isn't a dirty word but it
is possible to compromise too far
and
when
it's getting to a point where it's
difficult to
explain some of these issues then you
know it's wrong
and yeah at the moment you know we've
got party trying to defend the
indefensible and they're doing so gladly
that's that's not right it's not fair
and it doesn't respect the country or
the office
is it about leadership boris johnson
stood there and said that under his
leadership
you were responsible for winning you'll
see that's what got you to parliament
he's right isn't he
well i i was elected as as a moderator
and as a centrist and i'm still a
moderate and a centrist i'm just wearing
a different rosette
so when it is a matter of leadership
we've we've seen you know throughout the
last year that there isn't leadership
now there's no integrity
and you know it's it's about time that
that was delivered to the country the
country desperately needs that
some of your own colleagues have been
releasing messages now that where you
have been very critical of the labour
party in fact that you've been using
some very crude language expletives to
talk about them
is that your view of the labor party
well no i think we've all said things in
danger um especially when things have
been very forceful before um
like service this is something that's
taken many months to come to you and
it's not it's not been an easy decision
if anything it's been the most difficult
decision i've ever had to make
but i do think it's the right decision
for me i think it's the right decision
for very south well some of your former
colleagues say they don't think it's the
right decision for barry south because
issues that matter to
your vote the voters who elected you
include things like anti-semitism and
that they say that you shouldn't be
crossing to this party well i like to
think i've got a very strong record on
anti-semitism you know even just having
a debate on anti-semitism at university
campuses you know just a couple of weeks
ago
i think it's a very different party now
we've seen it with recent survey results
from the jewish labour movement where
actually people are much more open to
not only voting labor but actually
joining
labour so i if
i can send one message to the jewish
community
it's i think it's a safe space
so should they
should you
be going back to your constituents
holding a by-election
well i think it was quite clear that
even the prime minister uh wasn't
calling for a by-election today and i i
think it's quite clear that they know
they'd lose i i want to get on with the
day-to-day job of representing the
people who elected me as a centrist and
delivering what they need and that's
talking about the cost of living let's
talking about literacy rates talking
about alcohol addiction these are all
issues that are really really serious
and the conservative party isn't even
talking about